remember
[Music]
[Music]
that you be
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mud
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
did you hear that faintly in the
distance that's the sound of Suzuki
having a heart attack figuratively
figuratively
because of course we wouldn't wish it
but we're back here on YouTube
Hey celebration things a little
celebration there you go oh wow that's
so sad yeah ah glad to be with you hey
look really quickly before we move on
here uh please share right now hit the
like button comment because the YouTube
algorithm has told everyone that we are
dead but we are not we were suspended we
had two strikes
we streamed on Rumble for a couple of
weeks uh hit some record numbers there
on the midterms for everyone who watched
with us if you want to see what the show
is like when we are not beholden to
YouTube at all not beholden meaning we
don't have to sort of you know walk the
Minefield of uh guidelines on Rumble go
and check out some of those shows uh you
can always go check it out at Rumble
it's a live show Monday through Thursday
if you don't see us here on YouTube
10 a.m Eastern just to let you know
we're just letting you know bookmark it
go check us out Rumble mug Club look I'd
love to hear from you here in the
YouTube comment section because I know
that a lot of you probably didn't watch
them Rumble some of you did
um we've always said that it's really
important to reach people who haven't
been reached yet that's why we do this
content on YouTube that's why we've
tried to create a hybrid system where we
can do things here on YouTube we can
reach new people which you can see to
the tune like things like change my mind
a lot of these sort of uh hidden camera
videos that we do things that go beyond
the conservative sphere the right wing
sphere well I know a lot of you aren't
right wing
um while also trying to be obviously
authentic and the only
sort of stumbling block I would say or I
should say the rate limiting factor if
we stop streaming to YouTube is if we
get to the point where we have to
self-censor in other words it's only
worth reaching new people if we're doing
so truthfully
and we don't know when that crossover
takes place where it's too it's too
constraining so you let us know in the
comment section if you still want to see
us here on YouTube just the clips on
YouTube and live streaming somewhere
else there are probably going to be some
changes here coming the new year because
all of us were uh we enjoyed ourselves
more not being here and Gerald was
actually funny yes I also didn't get us
banned from Rumble so that's great I
know yeah true well partially they did
give me a phone call by the way yeah
we're gonna have to be careful with some
of the jokes that you made about the uh
no the drag queen story hours and the
prizes
all right so uh
oh yeah by the way we have a change of
mind up on YouTube when we were banned
that went up on uh mug club that went up
on uh of course on Rumble it's here it's
available on YouTube all right Gerald a
is here with me how are you sir I'm
doing well how are you I took some time
so we have to move on it doesn't matter
how I'm doing it you love them uh
fastest man on his feet we actually
still have some tickets not many uh
December 3rd Baltimore Maryland that's
the last show of the rebels with a cause
tour lotto.com tour how are you Dave
Ahoy good uh and you're good I'm okay
yeah I'm okay I just I feel nervous
again because we never know what's going
to get us removed from YouTube no it
could be anything at any moment right I
think I'm gonna do my best to not be the
problem well you know what's surprising
Gerald was the problem twice I know and
then once was Carrie Lake that's true I
have never been the problem
look at that it doesn't make any sense
they just want you to turn on your own
that's true well here's the here's you
know you thought like we're gonna ease
into this
it's like a human Cannonball because
before we go oh I need to tell you what
we're getting to gerrymandering we're
going to be talking about that who yes
we're going to be talking about uh
gerrymandering we're going to be talking
about uh Trump of course being back on
Twitter and uh we have a time to close
for Nancy Pelosi but this is an issue of
course after these elections right now
the left is trying to Gaslight you into
believing that Republicans conservatives
are only winning because of
redistricting and gerrymandering it's
something that a lot of people have
asked me to explain so we'll take some
time to do it today but I will tell you
this Marley was dead to begin with it
benefits Democrats overwhelmingly you
need to keep in mind that Republicans
won by 5 million in the popular vote the
country is in fact shifting right as a
population
you there's a silver lining there we
weren't able to talk about this on
YouTube because we were suspended band
right before the midterms
weird it's private
uh but the country is veering right
that's something that you guys need to
know there is a silver it's not all doom
and gloom and they're trying to lie to
you and say well the only reason that
Republicans won the house at all is
because of redistricting it's the exact
opposite so all references available at
credit.com coming up
of the cannon here
everyone
because we know we're on YouTube yes
we often do a little like we have a clip
we like to laugh
uh that we show you and we usually react
to but I've been made aware from
producers beforehand that we have to be
very careful
because uh what you're about to watch is
in Brazilian I believe it's Brazil's got
talents whatever the equivalent
a trans deaf and mute person uh
competing did this person win can we
confirm
after a beautiful transmute deaf person
and you've seen this but you haven't
seen all of it a beautiful rendition of
remember we're on YouTube uh Whitney
Houston's I Will Always Love You
Brazilian deaf new Trans woman sings
Whitney Houston I Will Always Love You
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
I don't know what to do
[Music]
is that a backup singer
[Music]
beautiful
yes they got my vote yeah nailed it yeah
yeah
okay let's move on to next
let's find a Nancy quickly
now it's the thing it's not let's not
look
it's not enough that people like we just
want to live no now you have to win
talent shows
okay right well deserved well earned Joe
Lewis just grabbed a handgun yes and
he's a dog
doesn't even have opposable thumbs
up so much harder when you try
when you try and hold it it's like when
you're sick and you don't get sleep you
just get worse yeah
I left this is uh this is just what
happens when you don't know how to deal
with the overwhelming joy and support
that you feel you didn't sleep much
either it's no the peep let's be on the
ground
oh
oh yeah
Oh I thought we were on the course not
are we just [ __ ] with people
I mean pardon my language I don't know
what else to say like here's the thing
like when you look at like straight
white CIS man like okay we never assumed
that it's like yeah we don't demand we
win a talent show you're deaf and you're
mute at what point you just say it's not
in the cards it's not the cards for me
there's plenty there's plenty of other
things you're not blind you can write a
book you can there are a lot of things
you can do with your with your remaining
three senses I feel that I could
give me the world's best masseuse he
could be the new Dickens
yeah but we all just and we all well but
there's okay Gerald's looking at me fine
well it's true though there's a lot you
could do it doesn't involve you know
audio make sure you guys watch us on
Rumble yes yeah
how do you do the cover when you've
never I don't
that's a fair point do you I mean do you
do this you could read music do you do
the baby when you stick your ear to the
is that what was that Mozart I think it
was Beethoven yeah Beethoven maybe it
was Mozart I don't know I pretend like I
knew I don't know we have no idea I
wanted to say it takes balls to do that
but I can't even do that in this
situation I don't even know come on I
know genuinely I do respect the
testicular fortitude
[Music]
[Laughter]
we have more people watching on Rumble
right now okay thank God yep oh my God
okay so uh before I move on to
gerrymandering uh Nancy Pelosi we
covered uh last week of course in case
you missed it so we did this Live While
Nancy Pelosi uh announced she would step
down as Democratic Democrat leader I
think we have a clip for those who
missed it but I don't know why you would
have you'd have to be living under a
rock and you should be ashamed of
yourself but here's a just a brief recap
there is no greater official honor for
me than to stand on this floor and to
speak for the people of San Francisco
this I will continue to do as a member
of the House speaking for the people of
San Francisco serving the great state of
California and defending our
constitution
and with great confidence in our caucus
I will not seek reelection to Democratic
Leadership in the next Congress okay uh
well and um thank God because we do this
all it's a tradition here at Lotto with
Crowder we of course recognize that
Nancy Pelosi had a good run we will miss
you and also because I need time to um
gather myself after the initial clip
this brings us to uh this week's time to
close when I hear people talk about
inflation as I heard them there we have
to change that subject what I said was
any sign of progress is always good for
the public when they understand what it
is and I think they understand
infrastructure
us
endings and Beginnings are ending and
beginning now why are you shipping these
uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops nobody said a word did you
even know about that trip thank you
George Floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice I
know that it's time for things to close
I know that it's time for things to
close
I know that it's time for things to
close things too cold
[Music]
I'm always dignified I thought that was
a very dignified act compared to my
exuberance as I said
[Music]
all right uh not photoshopped no no
really that's not look that's not my
criticism of Nancy Pelosi that is not
even that's not even top five for an old
lady
she keeps rocking in the D word there's
the little bit of a Mrs Robinson yeah
going on yeah a little bit unless you
have to talk to her then you leave I'm
sorry I'm sorry Miss Pelosi that's the
worst thing I ever said in my life I
apologize
all right so uh here's another uh piece
of uh of Good News by the way and we
have a change of mind going up tomorrow
for those of you on YouTube watching
right now uh Donald Trump Wednesday not
tomorrow oh sorry tomorrow Tuesday
Wednesday it's tough for me to keep
track of the days here it's almost
Thanksgiving so that's true I didn't get
to didn't get much sleep but uh I can't
still
I can't uh
you have to understand I've been here
since 2009 on YouTube and I've been
doing this program Jill you were with me
in 2014 2015 where we talked about sort
of how we were veering into the trans
territory and and how far it would go
and and our wildest dreams never
never would I have imagined that we'd be
doing a program like this such talent so
uh president Donald Trump is uh back on
Twitter and uh people like Adam
kinzinger
I don't even know why he's still a thing
they're of course freaking out about it
well look I mean I get that people are
on all sides of this debate the fact
that he did it with a poll of which you
know however many person of those could
have been Bots that aren't real people
voting in that oh now secondarily I
don't know if you know that decision
should be made by some poll I mean what
happened I I if remember specifically
when this was all done so Not only was
he lighting and accelerating the fire on
January 6 also before January sex with
his conspiracies at the end of the day
he said this is what you get when a
victory is so unceremoniously basically
taken away from the American people so
not only when it was when it was done
did he have any remorse he said well of
course you guys had an Insurrection
because that's what you get when you
steal an election hey by the way nothing
up my sleeves we are live right now
let's go to CNN where a disgruntled
fired employee of Twitter looks exactly
how you would expect them to coming up
next winter is that a double nose ring
and they're like cut cut
that used to be a job application in the
trash yes
it's not anymore that's a fired employee
this is where we are right now people
are hey how do we get the straight scoop
let's interview employees who were angry
that they would have to work hard
yeah the only way anybody's ever been
successful in business ah something
along those lines something I don't want
to be so rigid in myself approximating
it yes yeah it's a general estimate so
uh Donald Trump here's the thing Donald
Trump may be back on Twitter I I would
suspect that he probably has some kind
of exclusive deal probably with uh truth
social where he is
um but who knows because deals are meant
to be broken with
Donald Trump yeah there's always wiggle
room and you'd think it'd be like a
meeting of lawyers and okay what can we
do because maybe this might be good to
use kind of like us with YouTube to use
Twitter to migrate people uh to truth
social and some lawyers would kind of
have a meeting as far as the exclusivity
in the contract but what I mean more so
it's probably going to come down
well as of last night Eric had made
about 90 million fake accounts oh wow
well you know what hey some people are
willing to put in the uh the old
Midnight Oil exactly uh uh so uh here
are two of Donald Trump's final tweets
before we were kicked off I just think
you should remember how awesome it was
well that too but kinzinger is making
the point like basically at the end of
the day he was doing this and it's like
you forgot to include these tweets where
he was trying to do something good Adam
right why would you do that yeah his
final tweets and I think we also have
some of his best Tweets yeah that also
as well so sorry his final tweets first
word please please support our Capital
police and law enforcement they are
truly on the side of our country stay
peaceful band
I'm asking for everyone at the U.S
Capitol to remain peaceful no violence
remember we are the party of Law and
Order we are the party of law that's
what we are respect the law and our
great men and women in blue thank you
Ben hold on sounds like he's leading an
Insurrection yeah do you think he writes
it like that and goes over characters
and has to take out what we are we are
the party of Law and Order that's what
everyone tells me folks I would never I
would never just say that myself they
say wow so much love too much order
you're at 300 characters it's too much
shorter too much but I see no we need we
need we need it we need more law we need
more order they say it's almost too much
it's us please we can't there's so much
order that's 400. yeah whoever uh
whoever transcribes those it does has a
quite the job of the editor so November
18th uh Elon Musk posted a Twitter poll
asking whether Donald Trump should be
allowed back on which by the way I hope
it wasn't actually determined by a poll
because it should just be determined by
what's right but I think he was trying
to make a point
51.8 yes no 48 over 15 million people
voted in the poll 134 million people saw
it
and uh musk tweeted uh before the poll
was well once it was closed actually
people have spoken Trump will be
reinstated
uh Latin which I don't want to read in
properly but it's vox populi Vox day
I prefer sick Transit Gloria Glory fades
that's why I got the tattoo that's the
only one I know the voice of the people
is the voice of God lower back keep in
mind the Ayatollah is still on the
Twitter oh good yeah I was worried it's
not about here's the thing I've said
this repeatedly it's not and we'll talk
about this with gerrymandering we'll
talk about this with redistricting you
don't live in a free country if you just
if you have laws it's whether the laws
are applied equally and it's the same
thing that applies here when we're
talking about big Tech and it'll say
private business no no no no not a
private business when they can affect
elections not a private business when
they have private phone calls private
meetings with people in the White House
people in this Administration not a
private business when they benefit from
section 230 and they're protected from
liability it's not a private business
anymore this is a wing of the government
if not at the very least the minimum the
digital Town Square and if you have the
Ayatollah if you have members of the if
you have the Taliban yeah
on Twitter you've got to let the guy on
who was a sitting president who said
back our blue and remain peaceful and a
candidate yes for office right now
that's also really important by the way
he's a candidate right now Joe Biden can
have no say in what social media does
with his opponent right that's
incredibly that would be as egregious as
as mussolinius Pol Pot as Peter shade
that would be as bad as any Banana
Republic that we mock if you had big
Tech deciding to do the bidding of of
Joe Biden against his political opponent
yeah so keep that in context by the way
hit the like button right now if you're
on YouTube more of you are watching on
Rumble than YouTube thank you that's a
good thing but we also want a lot of
people here on YouTube so you know how
to migrate somewhere else uh by the way
he was reinstated Jordan Peterson I
Believe by Martin Peterson did yeah I
don't know if Babylon B James Lindsay uh
I don't know if they were reinstated but
of course Donald Trump he was not the
only conservative who had been removed
so this is this is good news it's not
it's not full throttle ahead but this
these are baby steps I think Kathy
Griffin also I have to confirm that fine
she was reinstated I think so well
that's fine well good we all needed it
was all it was to that point we made
that point when he banned her basically
saying he this is probably 8D chess he's
gonna bring her back at some point and
then they can't complain right
yeah well done and then everyone
complained that she was back not that it
was not that they thought she shouldn't
be allowed legally
she's back it was the photos of her yes
off-putting they're like oh no please
don't remove her thank God yeah or if
you're a national contest winner of a
talent show in uh in Brazil
what do you think about Kathy Griffin
thank you orca
Gerald's right he brought her back yes
oh
[Applause]
yeah
so uh the American defense
smash that you would never just to be
clear you would never make fun of
someone for that it's just look I think
it's fair to say
oh no one's me does that sound like I
will always love you though
is that the best Whitney Houston I've
heard I don't know
no no just imagine we need to re-edit
that if someone hasn't done that uh
Kevin Costner bodyguard pulling her
across just
not quite as much boy I'm gonna keep
that joke to myself
you guys later
tell us on Rumble yes there you go tell
us on Rumble he could do with any song
you replace Elliott Smith's needle in
the hay in Royal Tenon bombs when Richie
Tenenbaum tries to commit suicide yeah
it's look it's just it's not this I'm
not saying it's worse nothing's better
or worse it's all Shades of Gray I'm
just saying it's just not the same
that's all it's about as pleasing to the
ears as her final bath
American Defense League CEO Jonathan
Greenblatt tweeted about Donald Trump
being back on Twitter for Elon Musk to
allow Donald Trump back on Twitter
ostensibly after a brief poll oh shut up
shows he is not remotely serious about
safeguarding a platform from hate
harassment and misinformation and this
is going to bring us of course later
into the idea of redistricting of
gerrymandering it's really easy to sort
of say well yeah I hate harassment
that's bad well yeah hate speech that's
bad yeah hate hate crimes that's bad who
determines it in other words if you say
hey gerrymandering redistricting is
ridiculous and it has been ridiculous on
both the side of the right and the left
the left does it far more what's the
replacement what's the alternative in
other words you're saying hey we can't
allow hate and harassment okay
you're complaining that Elon Musk made a
decision to allow what you determined to
be hate and harassment how do you
determine hate and harassment okay you
don't want districts being determined
this way how do you want it determined
Oh by a special committee that you
appoint in your States you always have
to look at the replacement because the
replacement has it's the only way it's
the only way throughout history that
you've ended up with fascism with
Communism with socialism it's always
presented itself as a viable replacement
where no one really asks the questions
going through the scenario okay well
hold on a second how do we determine
this uh of course celebrity atheist Sam
Harris tweeted the prevailing opinion
among quote free speech absolutists you
know the people of whom he made a lot of
money appears to be that this platform
in order to become healthy must
helplessly publish the malicious lies of
any Maniac at scale regardless of the
consequences good luck with that hey I'm
done with this guy
remember this is Harris the same guy who
said that he was fine
this was a guy by the way obviously a
lot of you tuned in a lot of you tuned
into his debate with Jordan Peterson a
lot of you uh tuned in because maybe you
were people who considered yourself to
be liberal but you supported the idea of
free speech and this guy obviously
capitalized and by this guy I mean Sam
Harris
this is the same guy who said he'd be
fine with Twitter censoring the hunter
Biden story but hunter buying at that
point Hunter Biden literally could have
had the corpses of children in his
basement I would not have cared right
it's like it's there's nothing first of
all it's Hunter Biden right it's not
it's like it's not Joe Biden right Trump
University as a story is worse than
anything that could be in in Hunter
Biden's laptop in my view right did you
nuts no that's not that doesn't answer
the people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York post's twitter account
like that that's a just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted
just look I will tell you this a lot of
the people even right now who you think
are on your set they're not on your side
look at the track record look at the
transparency Sam Harris I I don't use
the term charlatan or grifter maybe he's
maybe he's genuine and he's just that
indecisive because he's such an
intellectual that we couldn't possibly
comprehend where now someone who we
thought was on our side or you thought
was on your side who supported the idea
of free speech who supported the idea of
a free exchange of ideas here's what
it'll say I'm not a free speech
absolutist but we absolutely need to
have these uncomfortable conversations
we absolutely need to be able to have
these exchanges okay how do you do that
if you allow someone to be removed
because of an opinion again
whose opinion
Sam Harris doesn't he's an intellectual
who doesn't think this through so the
alternative is what about what about
Jordan Peterson don't you consider him a
friend don't you consider him a friend
Sam Harris because it's the same
standard that you're using now saying
Donald Trump shouldn't be allowed that
banned your friend where
are you for your friend yeah it's not so
much that he's not an intellectual it's
that he's a spineless [ __ ] yeah do you
know how many atrocities in history have
been covered with those three words it
was warranted right
he's supposed to be a fairly smart
individual I'm not taking that away from
him right very very very smart guy
that's really the best argument you can
come up with you've done no research to
understand that that's never a good way
to put he's done research he just
justifies it how do you hey look let me
ask you this how do you come to a
conclusion and what standard do you use
that allows uh Dr Jordan Peterson to
remain on Twitter
and Donald Trump to be removed
everyone else you can comment below I
would love to hear Sam Harris's solution
into that yeah how it has to be
subjective you have to give that power
to a person to consol it and by the way
it's not lost on me that Elon Musk
effectively through executive order with
a stroke of a pen is allowing Donald
Trump back on but again the standard
that I'm using here at least the length
through him through which I'm looking is
through the stroke of a pen is the
person allowing more freedom
he's not making decisions that remove
Freedom Sam Harris is give unto us a
king we want less freedom I want the
right person to say Jordan Peterson
you're allowed but Donald Trump you're
not how does that work out in the long
run do not be fooled
by the intellectuals by the
Intelligentsia if they're not even able
to give you a basic rationalization of a
position that by the way cannot be
rationalized there is no
solution there is no answer offered that
is sufficient
it has to be well it's because I feel
this way I ultimately think that Jordan
Peterson's sins were not as egregious
okay that's your opinion though and your
opinion is very often wrong because even
though you're an intellectual you say
things like this that are stupid
he's just spinning though he's not
really coming up with anything that's
why he's saying crazy stuff like if he
had 18 dead kids in the basement or
whatever it wouldn't matter it's like
well no it would a lot yeah I would hope
it would be worse than Trump College yes
that's a very good point the
intellectual saying it wouldn't matter
well you know what uh every court of law
begs to differ yeah this
one's completely legal the other one is
not at all yeah the other is multiple
counts of illegal activity yeah yeah the
worst kind of murder I mean it's
borderline again it's all Shades of Gray
folks it's all gray these days by the
way just to just so we can refresh to uh
your memory thanks to Elon here's some
of the uh gems from Donald Trump on
Twitter that are now available again for
your viewing pleasure that's something
that I think people don't realize these
were lost to the archives
it really is I remember this one Robert
Pattinson should not take back Kirsten
Stewart Christian Stewart they have a
thing about that it's Christian or
Christian
don't really care she's a [ __ ]
Robert Pattinson should not take back I
can't I always get it wrong should that
take back Christian Stewart she cheated
on him like a dog it will do it again
just watch he can do much better
he's my favorite one too this is
probably my favorite he he starts it
with you know dick and starts with
Marley was dead to begin with that's
what we call front loading foreshadowing
that's what Donald Trump did with this
tweet very deeply
Heaven elect folks excuse me rep weiner
is back on Twitter
all girls under the age of 18.
oh goes under the age of 18. block him
immediately folks I never saw that one
that would be the best tweet ever
at the age of 18.
but in that same vein Bernie Frank
looked disgusting
nipples excuse me nipples protruding in
his blue shirt before Congress very very
disrespectful like he consciously aimed
his protruding blue shirt nipples at
Congress his dibblies he's not wrong
though
he does just have his breasts out excuse
me no he aimed those Ariel is at
Congress
man even a mirror like milk
[Laughter]
is it cold in here
nepalator [ __ ]
[Laughter]
understand that this is going to be far
more entertaining you are a liar I
really hope he starts tweeting again
come on dude I hope his first tweet is
something about that guy's nipples uh
yes I think so speaking of which it
looks what is it uh Joe I think we have
some well no we have you know he had
another thing about uh um what's his
name uh gosh Alex Jones well I don't
yeah he's keeping some accounts still
banned unfortunately we'll see what
happens actually though we do have some
breaking news though real quick
[Music]
oh it looks like the uh oh God why are
you guys doing this to me looks like the
Brazilian deaf mute sensation is
addressing uh
her victory
it's like Quentin Tarantino well look
that is hey that interview is uh well
deserved it's the champagne of Victory
yes it is yeah well said good for you
yeah I agree okay let's go on to
gerrymandering and redistricting uh
you've heard this old Trope unless is
there something I'm missing there Gerald
is this real I don't know are we sure
this is real I don't know sure I believe
they rubbed peanut butter on her gums
okay get her to talk this is something I
wanted to address and uh I do have a
question for you
um
you can comment below if you're here on
YouTube because again the algorithm
tells everyone that uh that uh we're
dead because that's what they do they
suspend you for two weeks have you heard
this argument this Trope that
Republicans are always gerrymandering to
win elections and of course Democrats
don't gerrymander and that's why
redistrict will use these terms of
course interchangeably and uh that's why
our elections are actually not free and
fair have you heard this and if you
haven't
well first off have you heard it if you
have do you believe it if you don't
believe it why have you been able to
argue against it how do you argue
against it and hopefully I will help you
to be able to argue against it because
it is irrefutable all the references are
available at cutter.com in case you
haven't heard this from the left here's
a clip they have rigged the maps in
Wisconsin it is the most gerrymandered
statement it is and in states where the
gerrymandering process has been undone
so that it does not Advantage either
party that is what happened in Michigan
and what happened Democrats ran the
table with ungerrymandered maps yeah it
turns out that people in Michigan want
Democrats to be in charge and when asked
to do so in a fair process a transparent
nonpartisan process that was the result
that is what Republicans are so afraid
of when it comes to giving up on
gerrymandering I don't think a democracy
can long Thrive or maybe even survive if
over a sustained period of time it is
governed by a minority of its citizens
and through the gerrymander the house is
often controlled by a minority of
Americans okay so in order for you to
not have to do so I have uh actually
been signed up for Adam schiff's mailing
list oh geez oh my goodness what started
this that's what started this so uh as
far as the overlay it's kind of tough
because it was an email as opposed to a
link on a website so he's been sending
out emails tasteful nudes yes
he's been sending them out just this is
a lesson for you with the cloud uh he's
been sending out these emails asking
people to sign a petition now to end the
filibuster why so that Democrats can
pass voting legislation and of course
the main Crux of his argument is that
Republicans effectively stole the
election through quote unquote illegal
gerrymandering and if anyone else out
there has signed up for Adam schiff's
mailing list let me know if you had
received this I just can't tell you how
much crap goes to it I have a separate
email set up so I can just it's what I
call my crap inbox so I just go check it
every day I sign up for every single
leftist newsletter it used to be the
fight for 15 uh you have Adam Schiff
Pelosi why would you do that well just
so I know what it is that they're saying
and it's why I'm so exhausted okay
I feel like Scrooge Who Saw hell on
Earth when Marley showed back up a lot
of Dickens references today because I've
been reading it so uh Democrats suggest
the solution is independent councils
right be formed to draw these districts
okay so this again what's the
replacement who appoints the council
what we'll get into what happened in New
York and how it was worse than any other
example that you can find I would argue
across the country
in relation to redistricting so uh this
brings us to some of the claims versus
the truths that are made in uh this
email Adam Schiff so here's the first
claim that's consistently made
that Republicans gerrymandered their way
to a house majority and that Democrats
over performed to keep it close here's a
quote from Adam Schiff he wrote this is
an email GOP legislatures spent the last
two years since the 2020 census
eliminating Democratic districts with
illegal maps and defying court orders to
redraw them leading up to the 2022
election their gerrymanders were their
only Saving Grace from a historic
Republican flop on November 8th
okay couple of things again remember I
think it's by 5 million or so the
popular vote yeah is that what it is
Republicans over 5 million yeah I didn't
know what the final count was I know
it's over 5 million so keep that in mind
because this is important to note when
they talk about Hillary Clinton winning
the popular vote for example against
Donald Trump well we have the Electoral
College for very specific reasons that
it's not of course uh our uh elections
national elections aren't affected
disproportionately by New York and Los
Angeles right that's why we have the
Electoral College the small counties the
smaller states that their vote still
matters and they're not drowned out
however when you're talking about
midterms right which lawyers were
talking about the house uh elections of
course this should be closer to being in
line with the popular vote
which was for a midterm still really
significant why because it's not a
national election people should at the
very least have their local
representative in their District be most
representative of their Locale I know
I'm being rigid
so 35 million is only enough to get you
one additional house seat than you need
right not enough Senate 3.5 million 3.5
million is a final count okay 3.5
million okay missed it by that much and
minus Gerald yes
so again that's the claim that it's
because of illegal gerrymitting okay
here's the truth
here's the truth uh Democrats actually
yeah
significantly from redistricting efforts
in 2022 along with uh gains that they've
made historically it historically has
benefited Democrats disproportionately
according to Cook's political uh and by
the way this is cook political it's
supposed it's non-partisan which means
probably slightly leaning uh left
uh they're redistricting scorecard this
was released in April 2022. you have
this reference available on the website
our latest scorecard projects a
democratic net gain of between zero and
one seat from redistricting alone
virtually no partisan shift from the
current maps and uh according to Vox
Democrats wiped out 12 Republican
districts by gerrymandering this is
according to Vox and they really really
don't want to make that claim were they
great
they're torn between gloating and their
false premises of oh Republicans only
benefit because of gerrymandering it
depends on the day so
and that's 3.5 million per no no 3.5
million total is how Republicans they
won the popular vote okay and now
according to box Democrats you had that
Vox sorry according to Vox yet Democrats
wipe out 12 Republican districts through
Siri so so at best it's zero to one
right so virtually right change at best
at best at worst it's 12. so none of
that is Republicans taking over because
they gerrymandered which is the whole
Crux of this email is that we did this
and that's how we want all these seats
what and again this is all all of these
arguments that we'll go through these
are designed to get you frustrated get
you confused get you overwhelmed so you
say yeah yeah just left them a point I
don't know a special counsel that sounds
better than what we have and boom now
they've got you and they've got it
forever yeah so this brings us to
another claim that they've made
um that uh Adam Schiff at least he also
made that very few house Democrats uh
lost their re-elections
and that Republican gains were entirely
because of her mostly because of
gerrymandered districts right so that
would seem like it's significant if that
was true yeah well look hey Democrats
very few lost the re-elections and the
only reason Republicans want you could
here's the beauty of it
you can observe that
so you can actually fact check it and
measure that no idea where wapo is or
PolitiFact no no or Reuters they must be
busy editing out a a Palestinian saber
on a flotilla uh writer so this is we
can't be bothered to fact check this
here here's the truth
six Democrat incumbents lost re-election
six so let me compare that again it's
very few house Democrats actually lost
their re-elections this is what you're
dealing with with Adam Schiff he's
sending this out to raise money and to
end the filibuster another big power
grip very few Democrats actually lost
their re-elections six
lost re-election
only three Republicans lost re-elections
one of them doesn't really count though
one of them was Myra Flores thanks to
redistricting oh so it went the other
way on this one yeah so they
redistricted the first Mexican
mexican-born Mexican-American
representative out
ah yeah they're the party of inclusivity
yes exactly well until they don't need
it right until you don't share their
opinion basically that seat will be
replaced by very soon by the way just
can I say this really quickly all of
this is enough to piss you off but just
remember the premise we have to get rid
of the filibuster yes so that we can fix
this problem what that means is we want
to pack the Supreme Court we want to
just basically do whatever we want to do
because we didn't have an election
result that gave us unfettered power
exactly so this will it did give you
unfetterment power oh my God yes don't
feel a buster gerrymandering I can't
wait to see this picture yes so because
yeah exactly oh let's pack the court
let's get rid of the filibuster now
you've gotten rid of two checks and
balances and it's all based on the idea
that we don't have any checks and
balances against Republicans
redistricting by the way can you
redistrict that for any Democrat who
wants it please I don't want it okay
here's another truth according to an
analysis done by the Atlantic
uh they in the Atlantic just so you know
tends to lean very left if you've read
them for a consistent amount of time I
have their uh their analysis was at this
election was more fair and competitive
than the past this is what they wrote
the 2022 election appears to be headed
towards the simplest measure of partisan
fairness the party that gets more votes
will also get more seats that's what
they thought
they were only Wrong by three and a half
million the sniff test would tell you
that in midterms which has to do largely
with local elections that's the most
popular party would get the most amount
of seats and that they would sort of be
congruent uh no oopsies they also wrote
also despite conventional wisdom to the
contrary the number of competitive
congressional districts has increased
since 2012. again the point here is that
the midterm popular vote should more
accurately reflect the will of the
country 3.5 million votes a couple of
seats
wow
so we have uh we have obviously more to
get to here on all of this what's
what is that what's going on up there
[Music]
um I know that's uh I think we should
check it out
[Music]
good Rancher
there you go dandelion and Mordecai all
right
if you eat all your seed I'll sing you
your song
oh boy
eat all your seed that's why I put the
xylophone here
eat all your seeds I love chickens eat
all your seeds
bad Rancher
where are my eggs
[Music]
don't look at me like that I told you I
want my face
You're Gonna Get It
Go with the good ranchers 100 American
sourced Steakhouse Quality Meats
subscribe today at goodranches.com
Crowder and lock in your 25 off every
box for the entire life of your
subscription good ranchers American Meat
delivered
[Music]
all right go to go to ranchers.com
Crowder just you know I I use good
ranchers that's the thing I love them
and also so does that benildarus the
fighter I think I think they ended up
getting set up with a sponsorship
there's a big black Friday offer if you
enter the promo code Crowder look go
there if you want to actually get
American Meat okay there you go you got
a box and what's in the box there's a
box yeah what's in the box hey you know
what's in the box nothing because the
rest of them out there ate it
okay well it's delightful I'm not sorry
yes
but you're fired back to gerrymandering
Fu Manchu let's talk about that here's
another claim that they make on the left
okay this is a claim that you'll hear a
lot that Republicans are the only party
that gerrymander
here's the truth and I want to show you
a little bit of a bait and switch okay
the truth is that Democrats invented
gerrymandering
well usually that doesn't actually apply
yeah to being real the term
gerrymandering came after it was named
after the Jeffersonian Republicans
created this sort of like weird serpent
shaped District in Massachusetts and by
the way I know this is the thing you're
going to hear like oh Jeff Jeffersonian
Republicans yeah okay
that was a direct that right this this
was directly linked to the Democratic
party just to be clear the Jeffersonian
Republicans they are Democrat you're
Republican so you go oh Republicans from
the Jeffersonian Republicans are
Democrats
and by the way it exploded as Southern
Democrats redrew the lines to benefit
white voters that is true so when people
say gerrymandering sometimes is racist
well it's true uh back when the
Democrats were allowed to be racist more
overtly
um
I can't believe that their sole argument
is hey we invented that yes
come on no but now they're trying to say
you actually it's because of you even
though the left invented it and they're
still doing it so that brings us to
truth number two Democrats still
gerrymander all the time again let's go
to just this cycle
18 state legislatures
18 state legislatures where uh
gerrymandered redistricted
manipulated by the left you know what
let's use Adam schiff's language
stolen okay that's what he says in his
email in order to try and push the
filibuster where are we with election
deniers he basically tried to say that
this was stolen for a very very slim
victory that doesn't make sense to
anyone who can basically add two plus
two well no so that's the illegal
gerrymandering and so they mistake the
Democrats do the legal yes oh is it the
same thing though well yes okay it just
depends on uh you know who's who's in
your court system this is what they do
it's the same thing with campaign
Finance reform what they're when they're
talking about what they really mean is
we just want to be able to take big
donations what they really mean is we
should be the only ones who are allowed
to read districts so again I just gave
you that number 18. let me give you some
specifics let's look at New Mexico
redistricting in New Mexico turned
Republican by the way a republican
Yvette harel's uh this was just to give
you an idea some numbers here if you get
a little nerdy there was an R plus 14
right this is how they were sort of
analyzing the election and this is what
we expect to D to Democrat plus four
you'll see these numbers on 538 yeah and
then she lost her seat by 0.6 points the
Republican did right she lost her seat
so it was a heavy Republican District
that they moved to Democrats they
changed it redistricted plus 14.
to -4 effectively the Democrat and then
lost by point six points which also
should tell you that they they
underperformed with the Democrats they
expected to perform with they can't even
steal it right they can't even steal it
right
it's like a Hamburglar taking [ __ ]
fries yeah you're like you can have one
there's no need to do that yeah you can
just but change it go ahead you can have
it uh in February by the way New Mexico
State uh house Speaker Brian egolf
blocked the efforts to appoint an
independent redistricting oh I wonder
why yeah at that point this is what
happens let's look at Illinois Illinois
they redrew lines again Democrats to
take five Republican seats and just
smash them into three districts so what
did that mean that two Republican seats
were completely eliminated so now
Democrats control 14 out of the 17 seats
in Illinois which by the way has still
largely been Democrat controlled works
like a charm in Illinois more of that
so they got 82 percent of the seats out
of that but only 60 of the vote right to
get it so that's right again we look at
vote totals not matching what's actually
happening with control right but that's
what elections are supposed to do
they're supposed to make sure that
control is given to the party that has
the most votes right weren't you guys
really up in arms about this when
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote and
lost the election where it actually
makes sense in a national election yeah
as opposed to your local representative
your local representative we need to be
able to mess with that but yeah no no no
exactly since your local representative
would be determined by people who vote
locally
silly goose yeah that's not right silly
voter illegal Democrat tactics are just
for us so I saw by the way a Trix
commercial where that rabbit actually
went to a convenience store and bought
tricks and they mugged them
then they're not for kids he paid for
them yes exactly so no they're for
they're just for children like do you
understand the voluntary exchange of
monies for goods and services you can't
beat up the rabbit and take his [ __ ]
look he got tired of getting beaten up
for trying to take tricks from kids so
they you got a job yes now he's applying
himself you're still gonna beat him up
[Applause]
this is why we're failing as a country
yes exactly
exactly right
kids are selfish taking his tricks
they're after his Lucky Charms they
never stop yeah they do yeah what do the
kid buy cereal yeah but never yeah how
about you go out and earn your Lucky
Charms you little prick pretty sure your
mom bought it yeah what did you do to
deserve it yeah nothing and by the way
don't think it's lost on us that you're
picking on the only person who's smaller
than you to take his lucky charms yeah
you're hurting a rabbit good for you
well and and again the [ __ ] yes yeah
that's true so here's how 538
describe the Illinois gerrymander effect
one of our greatest presidents Abraham
Lincoln was a republican from Illinois
but the State's new gerrymandered
Congressional map seems hell-bent on
making Republican congressmen from
Illinois an endangered species
that's good writing there someone would
say that's by Design yeah someone said
this by Design 60 of the vote but 82
percent of the representation hmm hey by
the way Republicans in Illinois leave
now leave here's the thing a lot of
people say should we stand and fight
should we stay in these states no at
this point these states need to see the
rapid population decline because it's
not going to be changed by the will of
the people it's not you can't change it
your vote doesn't matter in Illinois
just to be clear it doesn't matter yeah
I don't care how many farms you run how
much corn you grow you are determined by
Chicago and its carp mayor
let's let's elect something that was
pulled out by Jeremy Wade and River
Monsters that's we want that person to
lead us okay oh the the ghoulie yes
hit the like button by the way if you're
watching this on YouTube again because
the algorithm says that we're dead let's
look at this is one that really gets
stuck in your crop New York
so New York we can look at their
redistricting efforts in New York uh
well some of them were wasn't it well so
M shift I want to go back to him illegal
jerryman oh it's funny you should use
that word because in New York you guys
put forward your you know redistricting
map you're commandering and it was
struck down by the New York Supreme
Court for quote partisan gerrymandering
hey for reference what's the most what's
the most important Court in the state of
New York uh I I it's I think it's the
Supreme Court yeah basketball courts
that's where I get my dunks well yes yes
absolutely so it was originally proposed
by the independent Council the thing
that we've warned you about in the past
here and uh approved by the Democratic
legislature so okay it's going through
this proper process it should be fair
right so after the 2020 elections Dem
controlled 19 districts Republicans ate
right okay there you go after the
illegal map was put in place but thrown
out by the Supreme Court thank God
that's really important this is the map
they suggest yes so they already had a
19-8 right 19-8 that wasn't enough like
we need more than this why because our
local elections really really matter
understand that and be familiar with
your with your local officials yeah be
familiar with your local Representatives
so 19 to eight they couldn't leave well
enough alone no New York Democrats
proposed a map that had to be thrown out
by what I'm guessing is a very very
liberal uh New York state supreme court
they were proposing a map that would
have had them 22 to four twenty two to
four but it was thrown out thank God and
so then we have the 2022 election and
New York right what we think of as the
most Blue State what was the actual
number 1511 Democrats 15 11. in New York
in New York New York State yeah think
about that
think about that why do you think the
left wants you in big cities why do you
think they want you to be dependent on
public transportation why do you think
they want you dependent on universal
income what look what because if you're
going to look at the districts it's
really just a handful of districts in
big cities the educated voter the
educated voter who creates cities like
New York City cities like San Francisco
cities like Los Angeles people like
people like Sam Harris the educated
voter you get an entire city of Sam
Harris's and then everywhere else votes
Republican it's not the ultra wealthy
the ultra wealth the wealthy of course
they support left after leftist after
left except
for Elon Musk who I just love the idea
that the richest man in the world is
basically a basically a 4chan artist yes
there's one exception and they still buy
his cars though they have no problem
with that they do yes they're like I
can't stand that guy make sure you get
me one though yeah they just looking
at slow which they promoted and they
subsidized for years yes I just I wonder
how AOC just probably every day gets out
into her heated garage just looks and
goes
I'm still gonna drive it he's smart
enough he should have something where he
just starts laughing when you start the
car yes just appears on the screen
I forgot to say the magic word just
shuts it off yeah exactly
start speeding up into a concrete median
no no no no no
this is where it's supposed to go hope
you gotta
[Music]
so Maryland is another example Maryland
uh name that movie line Gerald got one
uh they're uh aggressive from the
Democrat they're partisan uh
gerrymandering attempts also struck down
again by Maryland yes oh my gosh they
tried to create seven
more democratic safe districts yeah and
they wanted to get rid of the only
Republican safe district and turn it
into a likely Democrat yes exactly just
just take your win you
on Maryland just like power only wants
more power progress can only can only be
get more progress to the point where
you're progressing into Oblivion that's
what the party of the left is that's how
you end up from like game management
yeah okay okay two oh right that's it
and I get that it's Brazil but if you
think that it's not going to happen here
watch I give it six months Brazil it's
had to have already happened here in
some form in some form or not allowed
them to go this is what we should do but
it starts that way it starts with that
okay all right same-sex man okay sharing
property rights we understand okay we're
on board with it too wait we have that
what do we do uh men can be women women
can be men then okay you have that what
can we do uh woman of the year has to be
a man okay you have that what do we do
uh children should be able to transition
okay we have that what do we do uh we
should be able to take children away
from their parents if they don't
transition that's what happens progress
for Progress sakes same thing with power
it's like okay look you've already got a
lead oh we need more of a lead yeah okay
look you already have the ability you
already have all of big Tech what do you
need oh we need to entren it into law
that it's basically holding to our whims
and can we can remove whoever we want so
that we can keep our political opponents
off of the platforms this is what has to
happen yeah and by the way before you
say both sides do it not the side here
in this room I don't give a [ __ ] if you
have an r or a d next to your name I
want as much decentralized power as
possible you already have both houses of
Congress and the presidency what do you
do uh we got to get rid of the
filibuster so we don't have to
compromise and then adds each to the
courts yes because we don't like their
their rulings because of the Court no
and then we need to we need to create a
law that doesn't allow our political
opponents to be on social media that's
that's very true as well and also strips
them of their funding but lets George
Soros give us as much money as he wants
yeah well well and that that Bitcoin guy
but he's gone now so how would you do it
what it what are you suggesting an
alternative uh no
anybody else let's look at Colorado
under the newly Drawn Lines again
Democrats want a dramatically outsized
proportion of the state seats so what do
they win they won 53 of the total votes
okay 71 of the seats jeez 53 percent of
the votes 71 of the seats Republicans
won 47 percent of the vote only 29 of
the seats look do that math 53-47 that's
a swing state yeah
71 percent to 29 is not that's not even
California no 71.29 not on their best
day but this is important for you to
know because it's all doom and gloom on
the right Adam Schiff sends out this
email and then you have conservative Inc
who they send out their emails and say
oh look every no no no here is it's it's
not Doom and Gloom as far as where the
country is going it is Doom and Gloom as
far as the leadership of the Republican
party and the conservative Movement by
the way
in a lot of facets because 5347 and you
believe you all believe that Colorado is
an entirely Blue State and electorally
it is as far as the people it's not
right that tells you it's a failure on
the part of leadership
your leaders are supposed to protect
your vote they're supposed to protect
your voice not drown it out with largely
democratic
I don't want to say Democratic Democrat
gerrymandering there's nothing
Democratic about it 5347 is the vote
71-29 the seats all references available
at lotto's creditor.com there needs to
be a change in Republican leadership
there needs to be a change across the
board politically they say the state of
our democracy is on the ballot yes okay
so for just talking 53 47 okay no no no
we want 71 of the uh the seats why well
because without the 71 percent as
opposed to the actual representation of
the vote democracy will fall in darkness
yeah aren't you worried though that
people will actually look at your
gerrymandering and say you can't do that
but no no no well how we'll just blame
the other guys for it well that would
force unfortunately that's predicated on
people looking at it well that's true
yeah not just getting the email and
going wow well that sounds terrible CNN
will probably run with the email by the
way I guarantee you stories will be out
yeah about gerrymandering the corruption
only adds up if you add it up that's
true if you take out the ad up it's fine
if you don't do
if you don't do the math then there is
no math well you don't have to look into
it to do it you're not going to look
into yeah so you know you can normal
people can do this math right yeah
yeah but you're not supposed to you're
supposed to okay why would they do that
yeah could you just turn the other cheek
right and by that I mean turn around and
bring it no no no here's another claim
that you'll hear from the left again
this goal is right now what they want to
do is gerrymander to the point where
they have enough control and then boom
shut the door behind them kind of like
the Sarah Silverman's kind of like the
Amy Schumer's kind of like the shot
comics of the world who now want to say
that you shouldn't be allowed to say
something's gay in your act lest you be
uh of course blacklisted and not booked
right they wanna they wanna make it to
the next floor and then blow up the
stairs behind them you see it in the
industry and you certainly see it in
politics they want to gerrymander until
they get enough control and then
solidify it make it set in stone they
want to Peck you don't think they'll do
this with the courts add the seats and
then let's codify that you can't add any
more seats
so their claim here is that Republican
gerrymandering the attempts are are
racist
and this is again I was reading this
email
with time I mean we had an aneurysm
so Schiff and I'm I'm reading this email
so I get that it's hard I have the
images for you and the text on a lot of
credit.com because I can't really give
you a link because it sent out in an
email which is kind of clever and by the
way the email self-destructs it does it
does it burns your computer it just
makes you want to delete it yes that's
all it is yes I'm gonna say hypnosis
really yeah I should have used the
correct term right when you see it it's
like you almost don't want to open it
so in the email Schiff accused Ron
DeSantis of trying to eliminate the
seats of quote two black lawmakers okay
that's the claim here's the truth
does Santa's actually vetoed by the way
the Florida republican-controlled
legislature they originally proposed a
congressional map he vetoed it
saying specifically that it was designed
to it was designed to sort of
disenfranchise black voters hmm that's
what Rhonda said is vetoed it that's the
opposite of racism yes based on what I'm
hearing yes and also received record
number of minority votes especially
Latinos weird do you notice too in these
emails they said uh Rhonda Santos black
because usually they would try Donald
Trump Hispanic notice they didn't say
Donald Trump black say Donald Trump
Hispanic why because of billed the wall
right well Rhonda Santos uh black well
what happened to Hispanic oh he he won a
majority of the vote across the board
Donald Trump made record gains with
black people they pick one group that
may not favor you for for a multitude of
reasons to say it must be due to racism
so if the scientists they know that the
dog won't hunt as far as saying Hispanic
as far as saying latinx if you're a
total self-important prick
so they say DeSantis black yeah and they
have to come after Ron DeSantis with
this there is no doubt in my mind the
reason that he is there is not just
because he's a political front-runner
for president along with Donald Trump
right it's because his State laid the
blueprint down for every other state
right to make sure that he had
representation in these elections that
I'm not just saying that because
Republicans won I'm saying that because
people's voices were heard right for
some reason we thought that Miami-Dade
County was forever going to Dems let me
right now bring up CNN because this is
just so you can see this happening in
real time they're saying lawmakers
prepare for gridlock because Republicans
didn't win their rightful seats now
they're going to give us gridlock when
they should have won 15 to 25 more let's
see what they say has taken all this oh
good Adams oh Adam he has cut so many
deals with bad people to get to this
position that I think he's not going to
be a leader at all I think he'll be
completely Hostage to kind of the
Extreme Ways of the Republican party and
uh I frankly don't think he's going to
last very long do you mean like your
whole state is held hostage by the way
you Republican representative in
Illinois who went along with this I hate
to use the term controlled opposition
that is for sure you see Melanie thank
you so now to a strange case so in other
words they try and redistrict so they
get record wins that are not
representative of the votes they don't
get it and Republicans make some gains
not as many gains as they absolutely
should have made that's why the math
didn't make sense and now they go here
we go gridlock good I'm fine with
gridlock if it stops Joe Biden from
running the country off the rails which
he's been doing a very bang-up job of
for you know a little while now almost
two years I'm fine with a little bit of
gridlock until we can get some competent
people in the White House yeah it's fine
doesn't gridlock mean something
something democracy I thought you said
democracy was on the ballot but more
people wanted gridlock than actually had
uh the representatives right electives
they want gridlock they want to stop the
[ __ ] that you've been pushing why
gas prices inflation when you're looking
what's happening with Ukraine when
you're looking what's happening
culturally the decay of the American
work right they want they want gridlock
now you [ __ ] about gridlock what does
that mean if they say gridlock is a real
problem they don't want gridlock okay
what would happen if there's no gridlock
what they're really talking about is the
last remaining Safeguard against this
administration's agenda get rid of the
gridlock so we can Ram it all through
it's always about more power being taken
from you and given to them
yeah it's just power and control that's
all it is what you want to stop it with
your local Representatives
good luck yes yes that's what we voted
for that are supposed to accurately
represent the voice of the citizens more
so than any other body so yeah but yeah
that's what we voted for oh yeah check
the scorecard well well yeah that's what
we put [ __ ] they changed the scorecard
they re-zoned everything
oh no wait that's sorry you said it's
because Republicans are racist here oh I
see never mind that's fair
gerrymandering and by the way DeSantis
noted that it was unconstitutional as
far as the nature of the district so not
only did he veto it saying that it would
just it would affect black voters
negatively contrary to what Schiff says
again also we get rid of the filibuster
which is even more severe than the
gridlock they want no more filibuster
they want no more gridlock they want
complete and total unfettered power to
be clear DeSantis also said this is
unconstitutional he said we have a
responsibility to to produce maps for
our citizens that do not contain
unconstitutional racial gerrymanders hmm
and by the way in 2022 three black
Republicans beat white Democrats in
majority white districts there you go
that seems like the opposite of racism I
said that before DeSantis painting him
as a racist with results like that it's
like how do you even make the argument
with a straight face isn't that the
go-to though it is and people don't
check into it and they of course assume
well Ron DeSantis and he's like Trump
and so therefore he must be bad and
racist like Trump even though Trump was
never proven to be racist
reform right yeah exactly more the black
vote went to him that's neither here nor
there and this only works this only
works if they have a Stranglehold on
media yeah and by the way big Tech this
is what happened they were traditional
media right the election that we we
streamed in 2016. that was a referendum
on Legacy Media they lost so then they
made sure that we could not stream the
midterms
and that was another referendum and they
lost our street I
oh Ox news it'd be
one and we weren't even on YouTube
that's why they're saying now we need to
control YouTube Facebook Twitter they're
throwing they're having a conniption fit
yeah whatever Elon Musk it only works if
you can use the media to Gaslight people
into in other words why are Republicans
racist because the median big Tech says
they're racist there's no basis for it
right well they'll throttle and block
those they can right so they'll throw
the show they'll block this show if they
can't do that to you fox they'll
basically just say well everything fox
says is lying racial hatred they're the
reason for all the division in the
country and then you're left with okay
well where's the safe corner to go to oh
it's Legacy Media we're the ones that
are telling you the truth except it's
only one side of the story and we never
bring anybody else on that has a
differing opinion that can articulate it
and so people start with oh yeah I guess
republi I guess Republicans must have
been the party that wanted slavery
because why because the media has told
you oh yeah uh Hitler must have been
right wing why because you've never
heard that it had socialists in the name
and every single policy was of course
radically
radically socialist that's one thing
people try they think they'll put you on
your heels like you're saying Hitler was
a liberal
I'm saying Hitler was a leftist yeah of
course of course I am of course I am
yeah the only the only argument that you
have is that well he was racist and the
only reason someone would say well I'd
put that on the right wing Side Of The
Ledger is because you say that right
Wingers are racist I say I put on the
leftist side of the Ledger Hitler you
know when you look at his centralized
government planning when you look at
disarming people when you look at his
Pop I say well also the socialism
because it's in the it's in the name
well I tend to put the the party that
has the longest filibuster in history
protesting voting rights uh maybe maybe
that's the party of racism Democrats yes
by the way that's number one and number
three and number three they have two in
the both again yeah both Democrats both
against uh yeah the Civil Rights Civil
Rights Act and by the way while we're
talking about Florida just take a look
here at the map the new map makes sense
compared to the old one this is overlay
F3
you see that little tala that's a 200
Mile Stretch just to touch black cities
together and have a black controlled
voting area yeah which is not right you
don't you don't go where the white
people at and put them in a circle and
where the black people at and put them
in a circle that's not how this should
work that does for Democrats ah well and
also by the way some awful Republicans
who didn't have the faith to stand in
their policies in Florida which by the
way resulted in more black
representatives in that state in white
districts hey if it's the party of
racism
let's walk through this Republicans are
the party of racism okay as Adam Schiff
tries to put in his email DeSantis is
racist okay let's walk through it does
Santa said no we're not going to allow
this redistricting this is how the
district should be okay so a republican
decided that it was unconstitutional to
redistrict in a certain way that
disenfranchised uh black voters okay
then with these new districts there were
more black Representatives
in white Republican districts that
elected them
is taking an L on the races is an
argument but they're still racists
Republicans are definitely how is Adam
Schiff allowed to call anything racist
on behalf of any race it's a good point
it's the whitest looking human being
I've ever seen yes he does it's
basically they can do a remake of powder
yes it looks like the penguin he's just
uh he's Shifty that's why his name is
Schiff that's a good point he's uh I'll
say it I'll say it yep it wasn't a joke
he's just a creep yep and everything
that he touches politically becomes
ausshift that's right turns to shift
he's the out Schiff does turn to [ __ ] a
political candidate
and by the way all of this we're going
to talk about this on mug Club this
isn't even taking into account the
incredible violation from the Census
that they're using to try and so they're
trying to redistrict this in the census
if you it fundamentally changed
to no longer only include citizens why
would you want to do that so even well
that's a good question you know what
we'll tease that because we'll talk
about it on mud clubs yeah because
there's some issues there that I don't
think we can talk about here on YouTube
yeah you don't want to get pulled off
for truth and no
again no or a Schiff calls them means
yes they've got the little me what do
you mean truth oh you're self-important
he's a cartoon yes I believe he's just a
cartoon walking Among Us hey tricks kids
beat him up yeah no kidding he doesn't
deserve your tricks silly Schiff silly
shift J mandarins for kids
now let me just recap this before he hit
me there's a cartoon that we asked to do
that by the cartoon cartoon the tricks
yes we don't
yeah
you do what you want are on YouTube I
keep forgetting someone it was a fun two
weeks yes he didn't have to walk on
eggshells we found a sensors of uh
wonderful YouTube yeah we didn't have to
worry about sicking cartoons on real
people yes exactly we didn't have to
worry that someone might take it
seriously and would be blamed for Nancy
Pelosi's husband getting hit with a
hammer yeah like what that's because we
made a joke about the tricks rabbit hut
fine okay so let me just recap this for
you really quickly Democrats that hate
gerrymandering when they're out of power
only because they gerrymander all the
time when they're in power this election
cycle gerrymandering incredibly incred
to the tune that is almost unfathomable
benefited Democrats Democrats lost a
popular vote by over 3.5 million vote
votes somewhere around there and
Democrats of course will use this as an
excuse to try and kill the filibuster
and we haven't even broached the topic
of the census yet which by the way may
play the biggest part in all of this if
you don't know about it uh we would
discuss it more but we can't we're over
time we have to go to mug Club please
share the show like it leave a comment
below especially actually would love to
know what's happened in your District
this is the beauty of having this huge
sample size of people answering
questions was your District changed how
was it changed did it benefit you do you
think that it's honest
we're gonna get to the census YouTube
thank you very much I do like this one
part though because it was thank you
Rumble it was but this feels good much
better I get to say
you hold on let me Savor this yeah
YouTube
yeah it's so important do you want to do
it Dave because like I feel like I'm
selfish if I take it because it is it's
I feel like it's a big day for you
though take it can I take it you can
take it
thank you guys you guys explain here
you're good friends
YouTube piss off yeah